for years you have asked where is the
yearly bottle flip challenge and we have
finally answered behold my challenger
Jack speed I see pie I have been
summoned I've been there all along
I know you keep me in the basement my
door is rigged he really does keep me in
the basement please my hair is Nathan
green hope the dice Ronny
[Music]
and good spirit about it's just kinda
haven't been able to shave
[Music]
what are you telling that nothing bottle
flip challenge stop clapping at every
bike slap if I want we have our bottles
if we have our GPS these people in the
bottle oops it's time have you been
practicing no I've been in your basement
I can't oh that's right I haven't even
been able to drink water well that means
you're gonna lose J damage as damage we
do read it 50/50 oh no we bottle flip
whoever lands the box if the other
person has to look at the red at 55th
that's right this is the most requested
video on my channel here we are bottle
flip challenge 2019 the annual and you
okay this is my bottle I'm gonna flip
this and curse the judge decapitated in
tropical forest or a hedgehog in a kayak
oh you're kiddin cat Kok it's adorable
that's a risky clip of the day wait
there's not make it a capitated dude
behind him or anything yeah yeah yeah
okay what do you want to see it wait a
minute look at doggy
we got doggy because we saw like oh we
want that oh do I get to go first you go
first since you're the news hey guy
please you're that away you're the
reigning loser oh you want to see skill
the Irish cutest duck ever decomposing
duck in the middle of the road this
isn't too bad but I'm gonna turn away
anyway what kind of images are you
looking at come on cute duck cute duck
cute day everyone subscribe to Tom in
there he did that before you did you
stole another me stop drinking out of
your pot fighting gang too much look we
all know you're gonna suck
[Music]
the odds are not in your favor camera
clearly a hellacious winner wait I need
to do it I have to fail yet
yeah
god damn you Volvic okay what do we got
communists shot in the head okay so
that's a that's a good start already or
a good commie boy I'm not either good
okay
oh it's the good commie no you're
tricking before I was like what does
that mean that makes me oh thank you
candy boy
people are getting the content that they
want out of this why because we haven't
looked at anything bad yet it's gonna
happen to you now arrow and I'm
operating camera Co Co timer tool same
time Oh three to see which one was
fighting on me
that's not German Shepherd golden
retriever mix yes please or a severed
head who's go hand-in-hand
okay I'm gonna be over here what is it
you're not reacting hey why are they all
good they're all good cameras yeah Edgar
please and get your butthole away from
the camera yes sir
you clearly huh
I got the gift I've got the Celtic blood
in me you are dammit awful at this all
these subscribers come on well did you
invite me over I am so [ __ ] terrible
physics over you're drinking too much
out of it now no I'm not oh there you go
my god dude
got the gift bum-rush ready to kick some
ass mandrews cut up and with razor oh oh
brush just bubbly Bob leave anything so
much now pulse hope you guys enjoying
this video so far if you want to join in
on the bottle flippin I have my own
bottle that you can flip that's right
the legend is true I got my own G fueled
shaker Cup very happy it matches the
chair is not just any
shaker Cup it's the gigantic G fuel
shaker Cup now I can drink more jeepers
we went with this minimal design because
the best part about this cup is not just
how big it is and how ethically design
minimalistic it is and not just that
it's for only 1499 sour cherry peach
mango and Cheerilee made delicious
flavors you need to try this out the
door it glows in the dark
do I need to say anything else buy it
now on bars oh my god oh you might good
[Applause]
you're too good it doesn't matter
I've been training all of these years
hanwen all its fingers broken or a cute
cat dress as a lion it's a lion it's not
I can tell in your lying
oh I think I realized I've been sorting
by most popular so obviously all the
nice one gets uploaded mmm Cameron nice
and easy okay believe the heart of the
characters what yours would have gone
back then they would've because I
believe yeah my sweet bottom okay do it
again
oh Jesus you're a [ __ ] terrible you
didn't do it either shut up yeah one of
them how many guys for the love of God
stay out of this good girl he's oh okay
okay ah this one sucks now oh oh okay
I'll go I'll go
yeah okay I'll take one for the team and
I read back to me on for real and deeply
cuted cute it sounds great Eric you
don't eat a cut doggy or a coated hand
oh oh it's the dog Oh what happened why
does your hand look like that there's
another hand inside the hand inside the
hand Oh God
take it away it's exhibiter okay watch
this Jack I'm watching [ __ ] it was your
sweet and energy okay because yours have
more in it I think a kid let's stop
trying to logic this okay camera one
the ultimate avenger our a monkey
shooting up a school I don't want to see
that monkey shooting up a school what
are you a coward
no I'm a gamer okay the ultimatum Angelo
Smith venture that's a crap I don't okay
okay okay I got it
the problem is we need to do steak two
one
you know you painted this one now as
well damn it no it was right in the edge
remnant Oh double rainbow
because bite kid I'm a huge lightning
strike caused by Kane oh let's freakin
do this
wait this is definitely assuming it's
the lightning [ __ ] you don't know what
happened oh so he keeps going did
someone die I hope so oh you get the
power lines
yeah what are you doing dude it's toward
the power of two well Jack shame that
you lost it's been great to have you
lost whatever okay tuber simulator still
relevant god damn it
can you also make sure you tell them
that the quality of this video is
actually really good yeah it actually is
and the cameras like the size of a small
child it is that's how you know it's
good it's a really high quality camera I
have no idea why your quality looks so
bad Jack have I told you about this
chair by the way no wait let me let me
test this chair oh oh yeah what do you
think about the chair Jack this is this
is great you know no keep the camera the
way it was that's a real PewDiePie video
this Cheers great ergonomic fits my ass
this is nice yeah how much is it oh it's
really cheap only 399 only 399 I thought
money rich people could have a chair
like this we're selling cups
hey Frances the chair you can flip them
check it out well you don't have G fuel
sponsorship Wow
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]